funny
I'm Greg Miller I heard my mic kick in
that's never a good sign when you hear
kicking when you've been talking for a
while like I hear Miller
gamespot cross kind of funny this is
Xavier woods however he's now going by
Austin Creed yeah his gamertag everybody
Austin Creed that's just terrifying I
don't know why you would do now
stop please I don't even Jesus it's like
concrete real nice underneath the skin
which is even creepier it's what we do
no big deal we're there trust me that's
like that on the list of weird things
kind of funny is done at this e35 yeah I
pulled elf there's this other guy you're
gonna see eventually this guy Alfredo is
gonna come battle Fredo yeah like his
name is Alfredo yeah government named el
Alfredo
like like a like alfredo sauce yeah
choice his name is Al and his last
name's Fredo
no his first name is Alfredo named
Alfredo Diaz okay it's like a name it's
like a real the Godfather anyways he's
gonna come back and I pulled his shirt
up over there cuz he's got abs he's got
you will have an AB off with you guys
so Austin you of course big time W be
professional wrestler you're this huge
guy
everybody knows you you're out there
you're in the rings you do it taking the
bumps as they say but now you've come to
e3 not just because you're a video game
fan but because you decide to get into
this youtube game yes with up up down
down yes what is going on up up down
down as our new YouTube gaming channel
so we launched on Monday and so far
we've got more than 16,000 subscribers
congratulations I'll give you one more
from the kind of funny games account
right now please and kind of funny I
need that of course your go-to kind of
funny I copy you can subscribe to both
see that's what you gotta do we gotta
start you gotta sell out immediately I
start doing it you got oh my god you got
a paper channel but it's awesome you
know I just think everybody that's
already taking a look at it and
everything if you can get us seventeen
I'd appreciate it we got over 160,000
total views on stuff we've got a sweet
menu of things for every week we got
five rows and that's what I love about
you is that yeah you already have first
off I I like to break news you currently
have 17,000 56 subscribers now you have
thanks yeah Devin thanks - funny games
now let me login is the other one
preciate you anyway so I go ahead thanks
you have a whole slate you came at
YouTube the right way yeah where you've
like days you're ready to go yeah we're
in we're instant we got five shows
essentially up up down let's plays which
essentially just a let's play right
we've got a Witcher 3 up right now if
like our week one thing then we've got
what's called super star save point
where we played Rayman so essentially
I'll play by myself get to a save point
call somebody in and then we kind of
hang out shoot the breeze yeah play the
game
then we've got gamer gauntlet which I'll
grab a bunch of guys and we'll have a
tournament of a game whether it might be
Street Fighter or MKX whatever it is
loser gets punished while the winner
wears our illustrious power glove which
is essentially our crown yeah
then we've got for the lols and so
that'll be like GTA mods and goat
simulator things like that and then
we've got jump scares which introduced
me to five nights at Freddy's I had
watched videos before hadn't played it
yet yeah then it's just me like in a
room peeing my pants
yeah and it's terrible yes absolutely I
don't understand why this became a thing
because everybody likes to torture each
other they're horrifying people on the
île learn quick on this youtube people
want to see you in pain see in
incredible amounts of pain that's well
that's what it is yeah that's what it is
you subscribe you'll see me hurting a
lot oh wow
be glad you're not on the hot pepper
gaming segment we're doing later on we
did some stuff with hot peppers oh did
you yeah don't try to steal hot pepper
gaming out shots fired not stealing on a
hot pepper gaming you guys you guys are
king of hot peppers it just happened to
fit in with something we were doing not
stolen at all do you want to be on hot
pepper gaming I can make that happen I
would love to be on hot pepper gaming
okay cool yeah I want to have a hot
pepper gaming stare-off eating peppers
and who cracks first geez lose any tears
first loses Wow and I hate peppers -
you're scary very competitive you seem
so nice then you get really scared feel
like I'm Marie so why though I'm a sabe
you want to be any three you want to be
starting a gaming channel if you work
huge into games but why make this jump
now I start this YouTube it's something
that we've been working on for a while
so essentially as I travel I'm on the
road five days a week yeah by day
through Tuesday Wednesday essentially
and I always try to find a park aid to
go to and so my thought was oh we've got
this WWE Network so we got show so I
would come to them and say hey I want to
do something that's like the Travel
Channel and go to all these bar kids
across the country so people like this
is a new hot thing that's going on
that's really getting a lot of people
invested in it and there was a guy who
said oh I want to make a gaming chair or
a youtube channel sure and so we said
why don't we merge the ideas just do a
youtube gaming channel awesome so
essentially now I get to go to work and
play games and wrestle and go to school
like I'm living the dream honestly and
I'm just so happy that people are
subscribing so it's thank you guys so
much as a YouTube creator I know how
hard the schedule is yeah I can only
imagine I don't understand how you're
mixing in traveling the country and
wrestling and doing this well most of
the time I feel like a human body does
this thing at night called sleep oh yeah
I know I heard of this yeah it's
remnants I mean something like it but um
I haven't experienced this in quite a
while yeah I feel like it's this all
this thing that eludes me and is just
off in the distance and I can't reach it
I'm trying but I just can't everyday you
a little bit closer and you remember I
could be making a video right now
exactly playing the latest game right
exactly yeah and that's the coolest part
is just being able to play all the games
I want to play all the games all the
time
so essentially having this channel I'm
doing stuff I would do anyway right but
hopefully building a fan base and being
able to share it with all your friends
and your family and that's a you're
talking about so then my question is and
this is again very you to be business
because of course that's what kind of
fun is founded that is so is this an
extension of WWE or is this your own
thing or how is this all shaking it's
it's a little bit them yeah more me and
as you see a soil in the channel I refer
to myself as Austin Creed right gamertag
so it's not rest of wrestling stuff I'm
not gonna come on in back oh this is
what happened on Raw this week or
Smackdown this week it's it's gaming
oriented if you know the wrestling stuff
awesome right if you don't okay you let
games
cool sure so it's not wrestling oriented
at all gotcha so the feuds aren't coming
with you
no yeah no this is guys in their real
life doing stuff that they do on their
downtime just having fun
like just like any other YouTube gaming
channel you're having a good time so
then what now that you've launched this
week was your official announcement
right congratulation thank you very much
you've launched you got this the ball
rolling what is the next big game you're
ready for that like he's gonna own your
life and define this triple so I am
obsessed with Final Fantasy 14 did not
expect that oh my god oh my god I'm 1147
bard I gotta get to 50 ASAP give this a
ceremony of eternal bonding with one of
my friends we're gonna get like the
matching chocobos and the react but
heaven sward is about to drop so like
right uh I mean I was kind of spending
time playing other games to it not not
getting out of Final Fantasy but like
handling it better the 12-step plan you
know you've heard about it yeah so um
what heaven have in store drops it's
it's over yeah so I'm just gonna be
sucked back in completely so now then
that's awesome so are you going to like
are you ignoring Batman Arkham Knight
I'm not ignoring but I will be playing
Final Fantasy more so what so here at e3
you've wanted the show for you've played
a lot of stuff yes what is standing out
to you that battleborn really God
battleborn is amazing yeah so we got we
saw the demo and right before we got in
on the computers to play they're like oh
hey Verne Troyer wants to play you want
to play with him like of course yeah of
course so like just sit next to him and
we're playing battle born and so coming
from gearbox into UK just like awesome
games and everything from them anyway
but the fact that like Borderlands was
one of my favorites anyway Borderlands
is so good so good so like I play the
person a little bit it wasn't like super
into it and then when the second one
came out I tore my PCL and my knee
because wrestling hurts yeah that means
my shin bone can pop behind my knee at
any given moment
I don't not a good thing so I was out
for a few months
yeah and so I ended up getting
Borderlands and played with all my
friends on mom like every day for like
three four weeks and then it turned like
three four months yep I'm just doing
everything we can have in a shooter mix
with our RPG yeah yeah once you start
leveling and you get that addiction you
beat the game like we'll do that I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna keep doing this
raid boss over and over he drops yeah
exactly and they have like four
different character so it's like oh this
is awesome you know I can run with
everybody
over and over again it's so like blood
or sorry battleborn got me instantly
because like oh we had four characters
in Borderlands now we've got 25 and
blood-borne yeah or I can sing
blood-borne I bloody very angry by the
way I'm a blood war makes everybody and
guess what blood-borne is designed to do
can't stand that game did you how long
did you give blood-borne Oh like the
first time I played it
eight hours okay eight hours and could
not pass the first thing a friend of
mine and I got it cuz like oh it's
multiplayer we can play on mine oh sure
you get to get to a certain point before
the multiplayer opens up yeah and we
thought we can do this we've got some
time eight hours deep and made it zero
progress I can't stand it I can't stand
I wish I had a disc you downloaded
downloaded being that this is the whole
problem with where we are with our life
you call me on the phone and you make me
mad I'm like will you go to hell you
don't have that receiver down and it's
like slamming a screen door but yeah
that's awesome I heard people talking
about that one just because we skew
console I think that's not bro you know
I got you I got you
we're we're down here in the dregs the
PC race is above us nothing wrong with
that if he adds it's super fun and it's
not it was one of those would just kept
me invested the whole time so I like
stuff like that but then we also just
came from Nintendo so saying like
starfox and everything you see Mario
maker yeah dude beautiful right like oh
you just change environments like this
and now he's swimming through the stage
that you just built you want to change
anything yeah click of a button the fact
that you can just take your imagination
your creativity and build whatever you
want but I think it's genius on their
part because people were like
essentially already doing this like I'm
sharing it anyway and then all these
crazy state well this is the funny thing
like I think you know we're all a bunch
of nerds around here and we're sit
around talking about it and my
girlfriend was like I can't wait to play
the stages but I can't I don't think
I'll build anything yeah the guy we're
at dinner was like are you kidding me
like you know when you were in school
with graph paper
you didn't design your own Mario levels
like no but there's like I did and so
did yeah there's hundreds of thousands
of my sentences
and the kids that didn't yeah guys like
us are gonna make stages that they can
play exactly yeah yeah I have no talent
at creating stages but I will be glad we
would make everybody make some I'll play
everybody but that Zelda was really cool
to me I love zelda so I've gotta try it
see right there in my arms so of course
all set
zelda is like really meaningful to me
and the sense of like when I was a kid
obviously huge nerd got made fun of all
the time like video games was my way to
essentially socialize with other kids
and then being comfortable with those
kids like learning social traits so like
Zelda was my game yeah for me Kurt's
power of wisdom it's like the way you
live your life and like a real-life
sense like I take care of my family my
people my friends and if you step to me
in the wrong way like I will end you
so that's what that means to me that's
his eldest you are awesome you are best
friends we're best friends we are yes
we've done that yes come and hug it out
coming oh we're tethered so the hugs
weird okay okay so no speaking of
friendships and things that are
happening yes I got this friend named
Dan Reicher
works at a site called you say friend I
don't think he has friends or people
that he used were acquaintances now when
he heard I'd be interviewing you he
brought up the fact that a long time ago
he clowns you out at Mario Kart okay
then this morning I woke up to a text
message and he said it happened again
last night on giantbomb down oh whoa
don't you destroyed you Savage lies from
Dan Reicher Turkestan right dirty Dan so
okay so someone came up to me and said
oh hey I'm introduce myself we're
talking because oh I'm friends with Dan
he says I spanked you in Mario Kart this
man has been telling people that I don't
even know that he's beat me in Mario
Kart which is a complete lie also he was
birthday drunk so it's even more intense
can't trust anybody birthday Dan I have
a serious problem with him yeah so what
I want to do is settle this because he
thinks that he's the man and all these
games that he's so great cuz ooh
he works at Giant Bomb and Giant Bomb is
like the best love you guys not Dan
though so I want to go to pax east and
go to the vent that they do and I want
to challenge Dan in front of all of his
people are you talking about paxil mania
or the packs
yeah that's what I'm getting at would
you like to come to the packs world I'm
the Commissioner of pack submission I
don't know mr. commissioner it's a
pleasure to meet you Austin I'm glad
you're here yeah we I will gladly get
you to Seattle four packs and I will
gladly let you be my bodyguard done you
can be there you can be the last last
year I guess last last PAX East paxil
mania happens right I'm there I'm making
sure everything's going by the book I'm
making sure that alex navaro won't
retain his championship belt good I got
sand Alex either
I got GF be on my side everything's
going great then dr. tracksuit
appearances back on me hits me with a
guitar course she does and then there
they it all goes it all goes south and
I'll go sideways dance thrown through a
table I want to make sure they're all
broken they all need to be decimated oh
you know what team right here that's
what I think yeah bring me out I'm crumb
Corrigan wrestling just got even more
stupid oh yeah Dan makes me mad you know
how much Taco Bell that guy eats too oh
wait you're from a mile away
that's the good news is that we don't
have to worry about him being around
much longer okay all the eats is fast
food the time is ticking on Dan Rikers
those burrito tacos are really good now
come on is Cool Ranch dodo I'm not
throwing stones at taco bell saying
they're not delicious if they ever want
to send a sponsorship kind of funny
comms way I'm not gonna stop them
mmm I'm learning here like you said so
as you have you have to just drop it
speaking of follow me on Twitter at
Xavier woods PhD and on Instagram as
well boom that's a good story let's root
like that sometimes you we don't see it
but it's probably up right now on the
look like right there if it's if it's
here yeah hopefully Kevin's putting up
he doesn't know Kevin good things oh
it's up its up like that Tim we're best
friends with Xavier woods I think read
now BFFs
I'm Austin Cole - hey afraid it is come
here Alfredo Alfredo
you need to sit here and diplôme your
abs get up here and show them your abs
give it a thing that um come on then oh
this is Austin put on your headset next
talk about your AB winner I'm tethered
in I can't move
now you I don't you've been on the show
for three days and you're always excused
by the microphone it's a confusing thing
it isn't really you know technology is
hard all right show me I'm working on
this not well he was flexing his he said
that we did show abs I don't know don't
show them just yet Kevin saying Kevin is
saying oh we're getting somebody for the
close-up now you're ready to do it we
argued for a while that he didn't
understand your name was Fredo like I
eat all the time it's great hold it hey
I'm tethered in I keep moving my head
and I know thing up yeah I we screwed up
all it happens it's Austin here just
started his YouTube channel yeah also he
conquered professional wrestling Tom it
was like now I'm gonna start a gaming
she became a tag team champion and I
wasn't even in the match
holy is how you do it that's right by it
took the championship always I I'll take
this I'll take it so now I've been
giving him advice okay cuz we I run the
YouTube right Alfredo's King at which no
twitch when I touch a lot what it what
advice does he need for twitch.tv be
consistent yeah that works for YouTube
is what is then are you going to VidCon
no go to VidCon the thing is are you
going to touched on know that I need to
learn with my schedule I have literally
like two days in the middle of week
where I can go do stuff which is
Wednesday Thursday sense that make it
very difficult all right all right that
doesn't make sense what I mean we're
shaking things up sometimes I'll get to
go to this sometimes I gotta go to that
I am going to Dragon Con past nine years
that's what I do me and my crew we go
out we cosplay and it's amazing what do
you cosplay us it depends we're
different every year and we have for the
three days we do four or five costume
because we're real
we put lights and all of our stuff
sometimes smoke coming out of it one
year I was like a naked cyclops this
sort of thing okay well you say that you
like making like like torn up floors
like Scott Summerside yeah but like
black Scott Summers so like if you do
white face that's offensive to my people
now is it hard to transport all that
equipment in gear well the cosplays yeah
yeah so essentially well when you're
naked
Scott Summers it's just a visor well
it's not naked all the way I'll take it
and make it kind of some sort of like
wrestling gear since leave so it was
like yellow tights and then like super
tight strap and then uh some some
sweet-ass shades yeah oh what a bad word
to say yes nobody's paying attention it
took me a while to get used to it are
you kidding no [ __ ] given say all that
what no we left the big corporation to
do whatever we wanted on usually I could
say effing I can't say I can alright cuz
the PG era no I just oh you just can't
curse I mean I can but like not one like
a cameras on but it lives forever yeah
that's my whole [ __ ] okay when I loose
all the time that's fine but I'm okay so
this is my thing so I'm studying to get
my PhD I'm working on my dissertation
right now you're such you suck too
I'm the worst you're awesome you're
you're jacked you know games you got a
successful YouTube channel you're in
professional wrestling and now you're
get a PhD yeah I thought we were living
the dream yeah we're all collectively
but no it's true when are the best
friends so now as you succeed we get to
hang on I'm learning sell it immediately
I'm holding on to you guys but I was
teaching them how to insert your oh yeah
I know funny calm yeah drop links and
URLs and everything I'm dropping links
like a like a link daddy a link daddy
daddy good what's your PhD in
it'll be an educational psychology and
so that's when I'm done with wrestling I
want to work with children who are
autistic because it's what I did through
my undergrad and it's just like super
rewarding just awesome all right every
single oh it's not married follow my
Twitter do all this stuff and then play
persona as
whoa do you like personas well I love
persona 4 golden dude okay so I'm trying
to have my friend who's sitting right
there I was like hey get Mike Mike as
well
oh sorry is there another guy right
there Oh male/female combo I try to
explain to everybody that they need to
get a PITA yes they are the bomb we're
gonna be with this guy Peeta
oh wait am I gonna be a leader without a
video also I have one of the reasons
that I love my Vita is because I for
whatever reason love kpop dance games do
the stage right there I know so tonight
yeah as soon as I saw persona cuz
persona 4 golden put in what 97 hours
friend that I was five hours deep and it
was just straight cutscenes I didn't
even get to play yet so um that and then
when I what's a project Frederic Miku oh
right so that I actually was in Japan
rent for wrestling and there were dudes
in this arcade that was five stories
tall dude chicks that just come off work
and let vine is all the way down to the
street I'm like what is this so I walk
inside and they're playing probably me
could we play a game then they buy some
outfits for this girl and I was like
okay I used to play that Barbie game on
Genesis back in the day and bar yeah we
don't like this so it's like dance music
games with j-pop kpop whatever we got
and then DJ max tune Technica any sort
of rhythm games we just act like you're
excited for amplitude I took out the
plane I'll show ya what you uh harmonics
and hung out with them but um what was
it maybe last month two months ago went
to this place called game underground in
Framingham Massachusetts yeah they just
got a new place in the mall but it's
huge and they were getting and reflect
beat machines the first reflect beat
machines in the States ever so got to be
the first person in America to play
those on the machines and it's just like
TDR any rhythm games I'm in oh so in
seems really good DDR I'll crush him
your question ring them we have so many
let's play to do when you come down
everything I'm gonna San Francisco as
soon as possible yes please
well also do you guys listen to kpop
Ryan comments does we know a lot of here
okay I know the taxi so I 221 this group
I know just kpop music because in
general are so over the top there's a
Korean barbecue places San Francisco
that plays them on all the team do they
play shiny that's my band right now I
don't know about that
I want comments always did and ask
somebody or what and 21 I don't know
yeah sorry it's 21 yeah it's 2 in E but
there's no 21 10 everyone in Taeyang
Taeyang how do I smell that he'll give
it to you off air we don't need nothing
other than of course kind of funny calm
and Xavier woods PhD which camera there
you go everybody oh also I gotta say so
on the channel when we have other
Superstars and everything yeah sometimes
editors will be into so like let's say
I'm in Australia and I don't have my
games case sponsors what up case with a
TV bill to the side but I've got my ps4
to travel with it around the world it's
the best thing so if I don't have my
case with me I can say hey Mike what's
going on I can't film asking them in
Australia so who say I'll do the jump
scare this time so it's cool we're
creating a bunch of personalities that
we can all kind of mix and match who's
on the show just to do a video for you
work we're down collaborations and there
we go they'll collabo everybody if
you're not following it Savior woods on
Twitter PhD you go do it right now
everybody go to youtube facebook / up up
down down up up down down I always said
you're booked for Austin creed yeah
gamer time I'll be smiling a missus
that's my smile face that's Alfredo this
car this guy's awesome it's kinda like
an Al Pacino face going into it's a key
we're back to the Godfather famous
Venegas
yeah that's true that's very true yes I
do watch those movies Jose and he said
it sauces on everything which is made a
best friend
I'm have you showed his abs keep working
them biceps I'm working everything else
I'm on the boat that's why it so this is
gonna go away
alright everybody that was talking about
working in our teams fan
this is gamespot cross kind of funny
crops kind of funny really funny though
kind of funny is so funny